[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHERINE MILLER: Hi, Craig.
Good to see you here today at
Google Cloud Next-- hopefully
a good event for you so far.
CRAIG BOX: It's been fun.
KATHERINE MILLER:
Excellent, excellent.
So Craig, can you tell
me a little bit today
about GKE Hybrid Orchestra?
CRAIG BOX: Yes, of course.
We've this week launched
the Cloud Services Platform,
which has a number
of components that
make it possible to build
a hybrid infrastructure
across Google Cloud in
on-premises environments.
We have GKE On-prem,
which allows
you to run GKE,
managed by Google,
in your own data center.
We have Istio 1.0, which allows
us to build a hybrid service
mesh that connects the two
networks together and allows
us to seamlessly route traffic
between the two locations.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
So when we interact
with this demo,
if I slide these
back and forth, what
will we be creating with this?
CRAIG BOX: We're
creating an orchestra.
That's the metaphor
we're using here.
And it's great, because we talk
about orchestration with GKE.
And we have a piece of music
which we are piping through
in many formats.
We're sending that out as
HTTP calls, REST calls,
to our Instrument Services.
When they are
received, the music
is tagged with the instrument
that it needs to be played,
and then that's
written to Firebase.
We have those
Instrument Services
running in deployments in
both our GKE Cluster and GKE
On-prem.
And then the wall you see here
is showing both a visualization
of the scale of
the pods that are
required for the instrument.
So again, if our
bassoon is playing--
has five units of
traffic-- we can
see there's five
bassoons here playing it.
And you can also see
and hear the music.
And in this case, you
can see, the music
is being redirected
so all the parts are
being played by our on-premises
environment on the bottom.
KATHERINE MILLER: I see.
CRAIG BOX: So we can see
the overlap of the colors
as the instrument
music is being played--
as the redirects are causing
the music to be played--
by those four
instruments down there.
What you see here
is a service which
runs on Google Cloud, which
generates music and pushes it
through various instrument
services that run
in our MicroServices cluster.
We have some of those
instruments running
on Google Cloud in
the same cluster
as the conductor that's
making the music happen.
And then we also have some
of those instruments deployed
in our on-premises environment.
Using Istio in its
multi-cluster mode,
we're able to connect
those two clusters together
to the same network
control plane.
So we're able to get traffic
sent to services based
on the hostname, and
it doesn't matter
if that service is deployed
in the Cloud cluster on GKE
or on-premise with GKE On-prem.
You can address that
traffic, and it will be
received by the right service.
Another great
feature of Istio is
to do traffic routing,
which you might
do to test a new
service by saying,
I'll deploy the new service
and direct a small percentage
of traffic to it.
And once I'm comfortable
that there's no failures,
gradually ramp it up
over time until I'm
sending 100% of my traffic,
and then turn my old one off.
What we have in this environment
is these little patch cords,
where we're able to say,
the music for the bassoon--
generally, the conductor will
give that to the bassoon player
to play.
We have scale, so we can say,
if we send five parts of that,
we need five bassoon players.
But we can also use Istio's
virtual services to say,
instead of that music going
to the bassoon player,
let's have a little pixie
come and take that on the way
and intercept it and give
it to the clarinet player.
So now, it says, there
are five parts of traffic
that need to be played
by the clarinet player.
Scale the clarinet up to five.
We don't need any bassoons, so
we can scale them back down.
And we can transparently
redirect that
without the calling or
the calling application
having to know anything
about what's happening.
KATHERINE MILLER: I see.
And what song is this
orchestra playing?
CRAIG BOX: If you
don't recognize it,
this is the theme from Tetris.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
CRAIG BOX: And actually,
it's a Russian folk song,
I believe from the 1890s, which
was made popular in the 1980s.
So a nice bit of symmetry
there, and a nice little bit
of interplay with the concept
of Kubernetes container
scheduling.
We'll often Tetris as
a metaphor for how we
slot all the pieces into place.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
And what makes this an
interesting problem for us
to be solving here at Next?
CRAIG BOX: Kubernetes has
become the API of choice
for deploying workloads,
especially workloads that
are containerized,
or things that can
build on top of that metaphor.
And we have had
GKE for some time.
It's been generally available
for three years now.
But if you want to run it
in your own data center,
it's either take the
open source parts
or take some third
party product, which
generally embeds Kubernetes
but isn't the same as the GKE
environment.
They're all conformant,
so we know that it
will run the same workloads.
But the management is
different, the versions
and the upgrade cycle--
you have to look
at a lot of that yourself.
KATHERINE MILLER: I see.
CRAIG BOX: So first
of all, the problem
of running GKE in
your data center
can be solved by GKE On-prem.
You can use the same
management console.
All of the things
that are running here,
we can see on the screen
we have over here.
But we're able to
see the workloads
in the single pane of glass--
Cloud and on-prem together.
The second thing that's
been complicated in the past
is meshing these
two things together.
It's connecting these
two disparate networks
so that just by
calling a hostname,
we don't need to care whether
the service is implemented
by this cluster or
the one on-prem.
We're able just to
say, call the bassoon.
Send it to those pods.
It will be served
wherever they're running.
And indeed, we can change the
split and move instruments
between the environments.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Craig, thank you so much
for your time today.
CRAIG BOX: Thank you.
KATHERINE MILLER: And enjoy
the last day of the conference.
CRAIG BOX: Absolutely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]